emmanuel macron's critics often call him
the president of the rich so it's not by
chance that the centrist incumbent chose
dena one of france's poorest towns to
begin his campaign for the second round
of the presidential election
in this part of northern france many
people say they've been left behind
the middle classes also want to be heard
people listen to the working classes but
what about us we work but we also
struggle each month just like everyone
else
i'm not for macron he's only for the
rich he gives millions to some people
while we tighten our belts
we asked mackerel for his response in
english please
we've been speaking to some people here
who really feel that the last five years
has been all about favoring the rich how
are you going to convince people
otherwise first it's wrong look at the
look at the facts look at the details
and so on
and i think i'm here precisely to
to go to act
face-to-face with with these people and
to convince about not just what i did
but i want what i want to do and so on
because i don't want to leave the social
question to the far rights people
because i think it would be completely
crazy
but many here disagree the far-right
party leader won the most votes in the
first round in dena her focus on the
cost of living and promised to crack
down on immigration resonates in this
town where half of young adults are
unemployed prospects are bleak and once
thriving industries have shut
macron le pen will now spend much of the
next two weeks targeting the same voters
from those who abstained in the first
round to the millions of left-wing
voters who now face a difficult choice
mohammed and nourdeen campaigned for the
far-left party candidate jean-luc
bellocho who came third in sunday's
ballot
it's going to be very hard to make a
choice between them because we have a
president who cares about rich people
who doesn't really care about the cost
of living even if he's come here to talk
about that on the other side is marine
le pen who just profits from people's
misery
we suffer in donor because people don't
have jobs and in terms of the cost of
living they've lost hope
hope is something macross says he
represents along with stability
continuity and a promise of jobs marie
le pen says what the country needs
though is something different it'll be
up to voters to decide which vision of
france they want natasha butler al
jazeera dinner france